Well, I've got my teams but I also can appreciate greatness.
I've always been a big Bulls fan.
I actually didn't mind when they would beat the Celtics.
You know, Michael Jordan was just, not only the greatest player of all time,...
...but one of the most charismatic guys.
I loved Rodman.
I loved Pax, what a great guy he is, too.
It just had so many great teams and I certainly can't deny greatness;...
...I'm one of those guys that appreciates it.
And it's great to see that kind of talent at that level.
Like, "I'm so happy that Derrick Rose is back, let's see what you guys can do."
And made the run that he made last year without Derrick Rose.
It was pretty remarkable.
You know, when I think of him coming back,...
...I think he's arguably the best player in the league,...
...I think I'd put him out there with LeBron.
Hopefully somebody to beat the Heat, but no, I'm excited.
I just love the game.